vous êtes écolo depuis longtemps ou
c'est depuis que vous avez vu Pamela
Anderson à l'Assemblée nationale
voici mon stagiaire Tom villa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis le soleil de ta vie bah
oui Thierry évidemment vous êtes le
soleil
c'est vrai hein aussi dis non et puis je
vous rappelle qu'on a pas encore aussi
pour l'année prochaine pourquoi c'est la
bonne raison comment ça va très bien bon
bah super petit petit débrief de mission
de la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière on savait Geoffroy Didier l'un
des 138 candidats à la primaire
républicaine et malheureusement on croit
Twitter Geoffroy n'a pas beaucoup
convaincu pourquoi ben comment témoigne
ce message qui dit Geoffroy Didier ce
soir dans slt tel qu'il est des idées de
vieux dans un corps de jeune
non mais c'est con voilà des des idées
de de vieux dans un corps de jeune parce
que l'inverse des idées de jeunes dans
un corps de vieux c'était tiré Ardisson
c'est quand même ballot
je suis le soleil de ta vie connard
très beau plateau ce soir Thierry
Christophe Dechavanne bonsoir bonsoir
Christophe alors désolé par avance parce
que voilà pour votre Vivement Dimanche
Michel Drucker il vous avait installé
dans un beau canapé rouge voilà
vous savez canal est une chaîne avec des
petits moyens et encore on a eu de la
chance parce que sur France 3 c'est des
tabourets pourris donc pas non plus non
mais sur le plateau d'ailleurs vous avez
pleuré en voyant vos filles dans une
vidéo attention c'était super touchant
non non mais vraiment non mais en plus
pour tout vous dire je vous explique la
scène moi j'étais chez moi j'avais coupé
le son je me suis dit [ __ ] Drucker il
a séquestré les gamines de Dechavanne il
demande une rançon
et pas du tout pas du tout et vous ont
fait une petite vidéo d'amour parce
qu'ils avaient la flemme de venir se
[ __ ] un dimanche après-midi
donc non en tout cas voilà pleurer
devant une vidéo de ses enfants à la
télé bah ça vous fait un point commun
avec les parents des Anges de la
téléréalité
vous avez racheté les droits aussi de
l'achetant des têtes de bois et grâce à
vous il y a une nouvelle tournée qui
démarre ça démarre le 4 novembre à
Angers et j'ai vu par contre que le
spectacle durait 3 heures 2h30 2h30 de
toute façon c'est toujours inconscient
parce que vous savez que la vessie du
public n'a pas une aussi grande
autonomie
avec un autre inconnu
bonsoir Hubert bonsoir Hubert Védrine
ministre des Affaires étrangères ça veut
dire qu'il a tellement voyagé qu'il a
cinq passeports un par continent puis ça
veut surtout dire que vous étiez le
meilleur plan pour amener de l'herbe de
Jamaïque sans être emmerdé pourquoi on
l'a pas connu plutôt Thierry [ __ ]
un écolo convaincu voilà moi le mot
convaincu ça me fait toujours marrer
parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a des
écolos moyennement convaincus ouais non
je sais pas si le diesel pollue vraiment
mais dans le doute je vais prendre une
voiture hybride voilà vous voyez Hubert
Christophe Dechavanne aussi il est écolo
il recycle les vieux chanteurs
[Applaudissements]
Nawel Madani notre petit rayon de soleil
si c'est la nouvelle prof de maths moi
je m'inscris tout de suite
danseuse qui est devenu humoriste tout
le chemin inverse de Bigard quand il a
fait Danse avec les stars non mais bon
le gros drame de votre enfance Nawel
c'est que vous avez été brûlé petite par
une friteuse voilà c'est le problème
qu'on vit en Belgique tu serais né en
Norvège tu serais pris un saumon dans la
gueule
il tient vraiment à le préciser Nawel
elle va jouer le 12 juillet à l'Olympia
foncé moi j'ai vu le spectacle au
Trianon c'était mortel elle est drôle et
dense elle a des danseurs sur scène
Thierry moi si jamais je ramène des
danseurs sur scène ils vont croire que
c'est une manif des intermittents les
gens c'est pas possible pinael il y a le
passage au Jamel Comedy Club qui fait
partie des émissions qui remplissent les
salles de spectacle avec qu'on me
demande qu'à en rire mais je pense que
la meilleure filière ça reste quand même
le Parti socialiste parce que ça fait un
mois et demi qui sont complets place de
la République et ça c'est très très très
bien
je suis ici pour vous poser les
questions trop con que Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser attention quand
même attention Christophe Dechavanne
Christophe est-ce que c'est vrai que
pour acheter André tête de bois vous
placez les malades de Parkinson devant
parce qu'ils applaudissent mieux
heureusement que j'ai dit attention
Hubert
vous êtes écolo depuis longtemps ou
c'est depuis que vous avez vu Pamela
Anderson à l'Assemblée nationale
et pour terminer Nawel Madani votre
spectacle s'appelle c'est moi la plus
belge alors bon en ce moment c'est pas
hyper hyper vendeur mais et vous avez
passé votre permis de conduire à
Molenbeek ce n'est pas trop dur de faire
des créneaux entre deux voitures piégées
[Musique]